the Joe Rogan experience I think they
should be doing it I think they should
have the fight in California if
newsome's [ __ ] asked and coming in stop
it
but without precaution you know with
precautions why is it your big deal I
don't know I don't misquote looky there
testing everybody and I'll tell you some
what happened to me I had to get a nose
swab which is we are weird man doesn't
feel terrible having more than you knows
it they dig around there and then they
pull it out I mean like gets way up to
the top of your nose it feels weird
because it doesn't I want it it's
irritating
but it stays irritating for a long time
stays irritating for like 15 minutes
after it's over that better than the
prick
oh the prick is nothing you don't even
feel a prick no I'm saying I did the
prick
there's nothing but is it the testing
better it's more it's active it's okay
the active bacteria or the active virus
rather whereas the other one is just
testing the antibodies and the other one
they can tell whether or not you have a
current infection or you recovered from
an infection but this is like are you
sick with it right now
so I did that and it was negative my
antibodies were negative everything's
negative I don't have it but you could
do that with everybody
these aren't it's not these in the US
he's doing that though right this is the
thing it's not like these tests are hard
to get anymore right there was a point
in time in the beginning of this
outbreak two months ago was very
difficult to get these tests now it's
not you get these tests you get the
results back fairly quickly very quickly
15 minutes for the antibody test it
takes a day so with the no swab you can
test everybody so you test everybody why
is that hard if everybody's negative let
them fight it's it's not I'm talking
about the healthy people that's
irresponsible foolishness it some plays
basketball because even if they had the
Cova these [ __ ] guys aren't even
showing any symptoms actly dude how
about baseball then [ __ ] are
you know far apart based off players are
get back to work MLB you know far away
they are from each other yes
get back to work yeah dammit yeah it's
listen it's not what everybody thought
it was gonna be everybody thought it was
gonna be like the Spanish flu or the
[ __ ] Black Plague it's not
thought about how about Dana said
reporters called in and complained to
the the Newsome to the government and
that's why it got shut down
reporters that's the word and he has a
list am I right on that Jamie I heard
these [ __ ] haters were like how can
you do this and called in the Newsome
was like how can we do this and then
that's why they get stopped so that's
why he said [ __ ] the [ __ ] media you
know I'd love to hear that list
I wonder see but the motive of the of
the people back then a month ago was
different the public's perspective the
information the more the information
comes in the better things look you know
the worse it looks if you're a family if
someone in your family died or your
grandma died or so I understand that but
the more the data comes in the more it
looks like it's not nearly as deadly you
can open your eyes the information and
as many as 70% of the people that get it
or asymptomatic which is just bonkers
right and then young healthy people it's
off the charts but just people in
general there's something's it's like
98.7 yeah like people that are just fine
yeah yeah it's weird it's a weird
disease take my chances yeah but I'm
pretty sure Dana was saying here's the
list of those [ __ ] who called in and
what you gonna do about Bryce I'm on
fire I don't know every dozen people I
block them on Instagram I talked to this
weekend come on I'll block me baby I got
a request so pay-per-views over here
like a [ __ ] for you man I know
you are right that's what's crazy you
think I go hard in the paint on troll
you you're too independent
I know but it's a good thing cuz I know
but but the show especially see when you
and him started tangling your show was
not nearly as successful as it was now
as it is now which is really kind of
funny because if here just like buried a
hatchet with you back then you'd be an
ally it would be helpful you come on the
show good all pump up the pay-per-view
it'd be great for everybody
you guys are getting millions of views
it's a different world now like now this
show is bigger than anything that's on
ESPN by far and they don't bigger than
anything you
she has combined all their shows I beat
all of them and yeah I still ride her
died for this
soompi friends again and the show keeps
growing
that's a growing crazier see when you
don't have a connection to a network
like it's basically a meritocracy like
if the shows good people to an end yeah
and more people tune in the more fun the
more they like it the more they enjoy it
the bigger it gets more realness yeah
but it's not overproduce and someone's
in your ear and you got an agenda
someone's censoring you just holding you
back and slowing you down and take it
easy shop you got to stop calling girls
[ __ ] yeah I know it's a piece
[Applause]